salut c'est dimanche toujours malade
j'ai toujours mon écharpe et toi ça va
moins ça va ça lui aujourd'hui je vais
faire une vidéo qui ressemble à un
placement de produit mais c'est pas un
placement de produit parce que je n'ai
aucun partenariat avec la marque que je
ne touche pas d'argent et qu'en plus le
produit n'existe plus potentiellement
mais c'est extrêmement intéressant il ya
quelques mois j'avais été contacté par
cannes givors qui était une application
qui avait lancé un clip starter qui
s'est terminée le 5 novembre c'était
avant la fin du kickstarter j'ai pas eu
le temps de faire la vidéo avant je
voulais la faire avant j'ai zappé enfin
j'ai zappé j'ai pas eu le temps
en fait depuis deux ans les personnes
développé une application qui permet
d'apprendre les 2136 je crois kenji
japonais kenji japonais officiel en
moins de 11 mois comme l'application
n'existe pas à ce jour je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs s'élever un jour ou pas j'ai
un prototype papier que je n'ai pas
encore essayé que je vais essayer avec
vous puisque leur concept c'est de faire
de l'association d'idées et ça vous le
savez ça me parle bien donc je vais
essayer de faire ça devant vous pour
voir comment ça fonctionne et voir si ça
fonctionne bien ou pas je vous dirais
sincèrement ce que j'en pense et je vous
mettrai dans la description aussi le
lien vers le site internet je vous le
dis la campagne kickstarter c'est
terminé je sais pas si le projet va se
développer ou pas mais je pense que si
vous êtes assez nombreux à vous
intéresser envoyé un mail peut-être ils
mettront au point un petit pdf qui
pourront mettre à disposition pas j'en
sais rien je veux pas parler à leur
place ils sont même pas au courant que
je fais la vidéo mais je crois que ce
genre de chose de concept en tout cas
d'utiliser les autres circuits de la
mémoire ou plutôt les vraies méthodes de
mémorisation ça c'est le futur de
l'apprentissage et je suis ravi de voir
qu'ils des applis qui font ça alors
qu'elle givors prototype niveau 1 à
prendre à bas la lie donc ça fonctionne
très bien
mode facile catégories de 1 à 100 à
prendre un à dix vous allez apprendre
des kanji de 1 à 10 comment s'est
regardés chaque flash cards adacore
s'est basé sur les flash cards hockey
regardez je vais mettre comme ça
peut-être on verra mieux regarder chaque
flash cards pendant un maximum de neuf
secondes vous allez revoir donc passer à
la suivante des gones avaient saisi le
sens ok d'accord donc en fait ça
fonctionne comme des flash cards à c'est
très malin
donc ici on a on a un petit garçon avec
une casquette est en fait le kanji
associés sont partis du camji pour
essayer de trouver une image en rapport
donc je suppose que ça veut dire petit
garçon enfants enfants cet enfant
souriant
ok donc d'accord la casquette sac taxe à
ses enfants
eh bien je passe à la suivante man a bu
le travail qu'ils ont fait est vraiment
intéressant puisque là on récupère donc
le kanji convient de voir qu'au et
autour ils ont fait une école et comme
on le récupère ici ça veut dire
apprendre cela fallait aller le chercher
mais quand même on a les jambes qui se
croisent et la robe sage peut le retenir
d'accord on à la femme qu'on récupère la
avec le garçon et ça c'est sookie et ça
veut dire m
apprécié d'accord c'est le double sens
aiment et apprécient sookie d'accord
pour verser un arbre ok enfin dans ces
bois un si beau à voir
et là on dirait un sapin avec un
deuxième sap a un côté ayachi ces petits
bouts est en fait un bosquet d'accord
bois bosquet en fait un regroupement
d'arbres voilà elle a sa place à la
forêt ça oui c'est la forêt trois sapins
ok trois sapins c'est la forêt bois ah
oui donc petit bois ou petite forêt
avant quoi ça c'est le soleil
ah oui d'accord là je vois pas trop le
rapport cher et clip de can't givors si
un jour vous regardez la vidéo mais moi
j'ai plus fait une fenêtre on voit un
lever de soleil ça m'aurait plus parler
en fait que le soleil du coup dans ma
tête je vais transformer ça en lever de
soleil et ça c'est la nuit un ouais là
c'est pareil je vois pas tout à fait
bien le rapport et là moi j'aurais
imaginé en fait les les rideaux qui
était en train de tomber avec un voile
et on voyait la nuit derrière alors si
on a presque le jour et la nuit c'est
quoi claire brillante d'accord ok quand
on a les deux indices de l'udm
does it et c'est clair brillante fermez
les yeux et respirez profondément
pendant 10 secondes environ
c'est bien parce qu'il ya tous les
circuits de respiration et de relaxation
je trouve ça intéressant pour se
reconcentrer
alors là forcément c'est très retrait
donc on se souvient bien ça aurait été
bien de les avoir dans le désordre ou
mélanger ou au milieu de certains qu'on
connaît pas lasser le garçon là c'est la
femme c'est le garçon avec la femme donc
c'est aimé apprécié ici on a plein de
darbres donc c'est la forêt là c'est le
bol bosquet le le bois de quoi enfin
l'arbre le jour la nuit
moi je préfère mes images je maintiens
ça la clarté la brillance mais oui c'est
très bien que je suis persuadé que c'est
très efficace avec une dose
d'apprentissage quotidien et tout c'est
vraiment cool de toute manière au global
cette vidéo elle est intéressante parce
que ça montre que avec la visualisation
et l'association d'image c'est vraiment
ce qu'il ya de mieux à faire pour
apprendre les kanji vous fait voir quand
même le cam givors alors ne vous fiez
plus à ça malheureusement la campagne
est terminée ils ont pas obtenu les
fonds et c'est aussi parce qu'ils n'ont
pas obtenu les fonds que je trouve ça
encore plus important dans de parler
d'aujourd'hui je sais pas si le projet
va continuer ou pas mais il ya des
prototypes qui existe il ya des choses
qui existent si ça vous intéresse
d'apprendre les kanji japonais en 11
mois envoyez leur un petit mail dites
leur que vous avez vu la vidéo ici
là j'ai pas encore fait l'apprentissage
des mots en même temps là je les ai
retenu parce qu'encore une fois ces
frais mais j'ai pas fait l'effort de
réellement les retenir
mais ça ça pourrait motiver en fait à
mettre le japonais juste parce que la
méthode me plais quoi j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu c'est une vidéo un
petit peu différente pour un dimanche
bah ouais pourquoi pas c'est aussi fait
pour ça le mental blog si vous avez aimé
ça n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en
l'air la semaine prochaine on a des
trucs un peu de ouf de prévu je vous le
dis pas parce que vous allez vite voir
ce que c'est n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner avant de partir et rendez vous
demain à 17h bon dimanche ciao
talât